good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
and exclusive on the state of the
British army could we fight a war
reaction to that through the show
including from the former deputy chief
of the defense staff plus where's Nadim
zahawi we're trying to find out and
we'll ask the government Minister Helen
wakeley exactly what the Prime Minister
knew it's Monday the 30th of January
Decades of cuts lead to a decline in
warfighting capability a senior U.S
general privately tells the defense
secretary the British army is no longer
seen as a top level fighting force
with a missile it would only take a
minute Boris Johnson claims that
Vladimir Putin threatened to kill him
during a phone call ahead of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
come clean labor calls on the prime
minister to reveal the advice he was
given by the appointment of Nadeem
zahawi plus a reminder of what he told
us about his tax Affairs last year
what's your reaction when you saw
reports that your own tax fairs were
being investigated by your own
department so I was clearly being a
smeared
Promises of thousands more hospital beds
and hundreds more ambulances in a
two-year emergency plan to help an NHS
in crisis
the second collapse of flybe we'll look
at what it means for the travel industry
as we dream of getaways to places like
this
[Music]
Rick Astley Souza rapper accusing him of
imitating his worldwide 80s hit without
permission
foreign
the Decades of cuts that have resulted
in the British Army's declining ability
to fight a war Sky News sources have
revealed a U.S General's Stark
assessment of the Armed Forces the
general privately told the defense
secretary Ben Wallace that the Army is
no longer regarded as a top level
fighting force as the UK provides
military assistance to Ukraine to fight
Russia Labor's Shadow defense secretary
John Healy said the warning poses
serious questions about whether the
conservatives could be trusted with
National Defense our security and
defense Chorus for editor Deborah Haynes
is standing by in Kiev for us hello to
you Deborah this is rather alarming
it is rather alarming and the U.S
general in his private assessment was
saying what many have also been saying
quite privately about the impact of cuts
it's not just the conservative problem
it was Labor too the Army and across
defense have suffered cuts and it really
shouldn't take a war in Ukraine to be
the wake-up call however now we are
facing war in Europe a prime minister
that really needs to have a military
that's credible and it seems according
to this this U.S general that's not the
case at the moment
foreign
has long prided itself in Fielding a
force that others seek to follow
a reference Army that Decades of cuts
have shrunk its size and strength even
as the threats grow
Now sources have revealed a senior U.S
general told the defense secretary
pictured here with his troops that the
British army is no longer regarded as a
top level or tier one fighting force
it's a sorry Slide the service hopes to
fix
but insiders say it needs more cash from
the UK's wartime prime minister in the
wake of Russia's invasion of Ukraine a
defense Source speaking anonymously said
about the Army it's an entire service
unable to protect the UK and our allies
for a decade defense is the thing you do
when you've done everything else but we
now live in a time where we need a
government that puts defense first so
that the country can be defended and
then also worry about its health is
education and its bottles
Ukraine Bears the scars of a country
that wasn't able to deter an invasion
like the town of boredianka defense
sources say the war here should be a
huge wake-up call for most western
allies to get serious about their own
defenses something that hasn't really
happened since the Cold War as things
stand for the UK its military would run
out of ammunition in just a few days if
called upon to fight and it lacks the
ability to protect British guys from the
level of missile strikes that Ukraine's
enduring
Rishi sunak was Keen to be seen in
Ukraine after taking office pledging
more weapons for its defenses
that speeding up the rearming of his own
military didn't even make it onto the
list of his top priorities
Vladimir Putin's full-scale War has
prompted well over half of NATO's 30
member states to unveil new plans to
grow their Armed Forces
this includes Germany which will
allocate an extra 100 billion euros and
France which will lift defense spending
by 40 percent in the coming years
by contrast Mr sunac has made no new
pledges though he is refreshing a review
of defense policy which could lead to
more money
a government spokesperson said the prime
minister is cleared that we have to do
everything necessary to protect our
people which is why the UK has the
largest defense budget in Europe and in
2020 we made the biggest investment in
the UK defense industry since the Cold
War
if the UK wants to keep parading on the
world stage it might be time for a
change of tune
so Deborah we're hearing that as a
result of what's happened with the war
in Ukraine Putin's Invasion the French
have increased their spending by 40 the
Germans are 100 billion euros what do
the Brits need to do
well the Brits that will say that they
already increased defense spending which
is true under Boris Johnson the military
did get an extra 16 billion pounds over
four years but the security situation
has dramatically changed following
following uh Vladimir Putin's war of
this country in this country Ukraine and
that's why they're saying that the plans
are now out of date and the military
needs more money in order to enable it
to rebuild as fast as necessary
otherwise the Prime Minister who seems
to really like leading the way when it
comes to supporting Ukraine he made
those um he was the first to send to say
that he would send Western tanks to
Ukraine and actually Ukrainian soldiers
are now arriving in the UK to learn on
those tanks he'll find unless he
supports his military more when he dips
into that cupboard of stockpiles to give
to his Ukrainian allies it'll be very
bare
no thanks so much indeed Debra thank you
and just a reminder that you can watch
the full version of my interview with
President zielinski by going to the Sky
News website you can also read my behind
the scenes account of the build up to
that chat and the moment Mr zielinski
learned of Western tank deployments
during the interview that's on our
website and you can also find it via my
Twitter at Cape early
meanwhile Boris Johnson has claimed that
Vladimir Putin threatened to kill him
with a missile in a call they shared in
the run-up to Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the former PM claims the
conversation took place in February
shortly after he visited Kiev in an
attempt to show Western support for
president zielinski and the Ukrainian
people The War Began three weeks after
the call
he threatened me at one point and said
you know Boris I don't want to hurt you
but uh with a Miss Holly would only take
a minute or something like that you know
uh you know Charlie
's under pressure today to answer more
questions and what he knew and when
about the tax Affairs of Nadeem zahawi
who he sacked yesterday morning Labor's
Deputy leader Angela Rayner and party
chair annalize Dodds have called on the
PM to come clean
uh this hopelessly weak prime minister
has been dragged Kicking and Screaming
into doing what he should have done long
ago Rishi sunak shouldn't have needed an
Ethics advisor to tell him that Nadeem
zahawi's position was untenable but
instead he continued to prop up the man
he appointed to Cabinet he must now come
clean on the advice he was given about
that appointment in the first place and
why he apparently ignored the warnings
well here's what the then Tory
leadership Contender told me when I
quizzed him about his taxes Last Summer
I need to ask you about your
investigation into your own tax Affairs
um what's your reaction when you saw
reports that your own tax Affairs were
being investigated by your own
department so I was you know clearly
being smeared I was being told that that
the serious thought offers that the
national crimeacy that hmrc are looking
uh into me I've you know I'm not aware
of this I will I've always declared my
taxes I paid my taxes in the UK uh I was
you know answer any questions hmrc has
uh uh of me but I will go further okay
I'm going to make a commitment today
that if I am prime minister
I think the right thing to do is to
publish my accounts annually that's the
right thing to do because I think we
need to take this issue in many ways off
the off the table
um I will publish my accounts annually
that's the right thing to do
I will look at you know what what the
options are in terms of back dating or
just publishing annual I think it's
right to do it what about your tax
returns that's what I'm talking about my
taxes I'll publish annually okay
and shortly speaking to the minister for
social care Helen weekly and um in the
latest edition of Sky's daily podcast
host Neil Patterson and Deputy political
editor Sam coats analyzed The Fallout of
Nadeem zahawi's exit from the cabinet
and what it means for Rishi Suna you can
listen to it by scanning the QR code on
your screen right now
the Prime Minister will lay out a
two-year emergency care plan for the NHS
in England today but he is being warned
there are no shortcuts to fixing a
system in crisis here's what we know so
far the plan aims to transform Urgent
Care following a winter of unprecedented
pressure a one billion pound fund
dedicated to boosting Frontline capacity
will be introduced including 800 new
ambulances and 100 Specialists mental
health Vehicles the fund will also
provide 5 000 more hospital beds
virtual awards are set to be expanded
with 50 000 patients benefiting from
high-tech Home Care by the end of 2024
and there'll be Services running 12
hours a day to provide more urgent care
for people at home avoiding the need for
Hospital admissions
last Thursday Sky News held a phone-in
program to hear patients experiences in
the NHS Carlo was among those who
contacted us he described being
discharged from hospital too quickly and
says he was left waiting for a hip
operation and a diagnosis for
Parkinson's Disease our correspondent
Paul Kelso went to meet him
did you feel like you were being
hastened out the door
subtly yes
I totally understand I totally
understand the crisis that haven't
but it's a crisis relationship which we
we could have planned for
and we didn't plan for it
well Saudia is outside the Department of
Health for us this morning and social
care as well of course
um hi Sadia so what is the plan today
what is what are we going to hear more
of from the prime minister
good morning well they're calling this a
blueprint but a lot of the the things
that are contained in this plan are
already in operation but the Crux of it
is to try and get people in and out of
emergency quicker so things like more
ambulances more especially trained
medical technicians these uh same day
emergency Wards so that people aren't
having to do overnight stays in hospital
they can come in be seen and be out
quickly it's all about addressing those
long times that people wait for an
ambulance and trying to get that
pressure off emergency departments it's
a two two-year plan it's backed by a one
billion pound fund but it's also
contains loads of other things like more
working from home for NHS workers
including for example 111 call handlers
but there is also an emphasis on getting
people out of Hospital quicker and into
the community into their homes and so
there's the talk of expanding this
virtual Awards uh proposal we already
have seven thousand of these hospital
staff beds at home now that's due to be
rolled out so that it covers 50 000 beds
by the end of this plan taking place but
also things like giving people more
rehab and physio at home now labor is
criticizing this saying that people will
be released too early that even if the
government meets its targets people will
be left waiting for longer than is safe
it says that handing the crisis in the
NHS to the conservative party just
thought out is akin to giving the
arsonists and arson is the
responsibility of putting out a fire it
says this simply isn't a workable plan
and that the only way it will work is by
increasing the number of doctors and
nurses and paying them properly
no thank you still to come on the
program for you this Monday morning
speaking to the General Secretary of the
fire brigade Union Matt rack
later on today the results of the
firefighter ballot will be announced
the world is shocked by the brutal body
cam footage of the killing of Tire
Nichols will get the reaction of a
friend of the show Dr Shola
and then later this hour we'll get more
on that warning that the British army is
on the decline with the former deputy
chief of the defense staff so Simon Bell
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and six British
children have been taken into care in
Austria after they were found living in
an abandoned wine cellar with their
parents Social Services were called to
the property in orbits near the Czech
border when locals became concerned for
the welfare of the children all of whom
are under five their father is believed
to be a member of the far right movement
who's since been arrested and released
on bail
teaching unions will meet the education
secretary later today in a last-ditch
attempt to avoid Wednesday's planned
strike action
if talks fail teachers will be among an
expected half a million public sector
workers going on strike on the 1st of
February along with civil servants train
drivers and University staff
sixteen-year-old boy will appear before
magistrates in Newcastle today charged
with the murder of a 15 year old girl in
hexham Holly Newton was trans stabbed on
Friday afternoon and died later in
hospital
the organization Restless says half a
million more people are out of work due
to long-term sickness than before the
pandemic and three out of five of them
are over 50. the group says chronic
long-lasting illness is significantly
reducing the UK's potential Workforce
a police officer and bystander have
pulled a man from his car as it erupted
into flames after a crash the lucky
Escape was filmed by cameras along the
famous strip in Las Vegas the driver was
taken to hospital
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
flies into Jerusalem later on today
arriving after a spike in
israeli-palestinian violence and
increasingly sharp rhetoric from both
sides our correspondent Alistair bunkel
is in Jerusalem and he'll be joining us
very shortly indeed
looking at what's happening as far as
the front pages are concerned today
let's have a look at those
um obviously Nadeem Jahar we very much
dominating the papers
um again today and the fact that he was
sacked in the early hours of yesterday
morning by the Prime Minister how are
the papers reflecting on that today
let's just have a quick look at the
paper should we
okay we've got a problem with that
um so instead coming up in just a few
moments time we're going to be speaking
to Helen waitley the minister for social
care talking to her about Nadeem zahawi
let's have a quick look at the papers
should we here they look this morning
uh rotten to the core is the front page
of the Daily Mirror for you today moving
on to others
looking at the other papers for you
that the Daily Telegraph for you this
morning as well
um the PM saxahari without a fair
hearing
looking at the times for you now
and zahawi acts as soon as it gets tough
on standards next one for you
looking at the eye
supporters blaming Boris for the party's
problems
and looking at the Daily Mail as well
splashing Mr Johnson's comments in a new
documentary that Russia's president
threatened him in the lead up to the
Ukraine Invasion final look at the
express for you and that really is the
story uh that all the other papers are
covering uh as well I could kill you in
a minute is
um apparently what President Putin said
to Boris Johnson
representing the government this morning
the minister for a social care is Helen
Whiteley hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program very much
appreciated
um
has Nadeem zahati been on fairly treated
well the Prime Minister has followed the
process that he said he was going to do
he appointed an independent ethics
advisor Laurie Magnus Laurie reported
back the Prime Minister saw that report
and on the basis of that he made the
decision that's not Nadim zahal we
should be removed from his government
yeah but do you think he's been fairly
treated well no I don't because I think
that process was exactly the right thing
to do the Prime Minister was under
pressure to act more quickly but he said
no he was going to follow a fair process
he did that so Laurie really set out in
some detail the reasons for uh the the
Judgment the things that he saw that
Nadeem zahawi had done wrong or had not
done and that was the basis in which the
Prime Minister made his decision when
you get appointed you get a phone call
asking you a set of questions which is
your opportunity to say whether there's
something that that the Prime Minister
ought to know before they appoint you
and also and say you fill in your
register of Interest these are the
places where ministers declare things at
the point of appointment and Adam zahari
didn't that was all set out in the
letter but what I'm trying to get to the
boss bottom of is are you telling me
that civil servants and the cabinet
officers propriety and ethics team would
not have alerted this prime minister to
concerns about the financial affairs of
Nadeem zahawi well I'm saying with the
Prime Minister didn't know about the
things then have come out and set out
about it well this is the process and
that's that's the process which general
means that ministers have declared all
all their interests and the things that
should be known it's really important to
make sure that there should be no
conflicts of interest or actual
perceived conflicts of interesting these
are things that you know as a minister
taking on the important responsibilities
in the cabinet office are saying whoa
you need to look at this guy's finances
and that isn't passed on to this present
prime minister I'm not going to give you
a different answer from what I just said
because what I've explained unbelievable
is what the Prime Minister uh knew and
as I said was set out in the report
yesterday that was why the Prime
Minister made the decision uh that Nadim
zahari had to be removed from government
okay the lib Dems feel his
transgressions are so he us he should
have the whip removed why they're wrong
well he's he's been fired from
government you know this is very serious
consequence because he didn't comply
with the ministerial code but he was
still elected to be a member of
Parliament and we can spend we can talk
about this one I will just say that I've
come here to talk about something that I
know the people that really care about I
do the interview questions
this is what my viewers want to know
about and I'll ask the questions in the
order that I see fit if you don't mind
um why should he not have the whip
removed are you happy with him still
being a conservative I'm happy with the
decision that the Prime Minister has
made
so you're happy with him still being
conservative and still representing the
conservative party from the back benches
as I said and he was elected to be a
conservative Member of Parliament I do
think no clearly uh as set out by the
independence ethics advisor it was very
serious uh what he had or in fact hadn't
set out but I also have worked alongside
him in the department of health during
the pandemic I know what a fantastic job
he did driving the progress with the
vaccination driving the vaccination so
that we got millions of people
vaccinated in this country from covert
head of many many other countries and
that's something I'm really grateful to
him for making that happen Okay Deputy
PM is next in the firing line
um he has something like 24 civil
servants who've claimed made formal
complaints against him for bullying how
can the PM avoid this becoming another
disastrous set of headlines for him in
the papers well the PM is determined to
make sure that there is integrity
accountability and professionalism in
his government that's why when things
like this when complaints are made there
is a fair and due process followed so
that is being followed in this
circumstances with the Deputy Prime
Minister as it has been with Nadeem
zahari prime minister got the report
from Nadine tahari's behavior and made a
very rapid and decisive decision to
remove him from government meanwhile I
would say ministers like me are we
getting on with a really important job
working on people's priorities I am here
to talk about this and I will talk about
that and the thing that people really
can't have eight minutes with you and as
I said I'll decide how we conduct this
interview if you don't mind
um are you not concerned that the Prime
Minister could find himself in the same
position with
um the Deputy Prime Minister as he has
with his former chem I'm not going to
prejudge the outcome of uh the
investigation that's going on and I'm
sure the Prime Minister will make the
right decision when that report's back
okay talk to me then about the NHS
remote monitoring um
how is that going to work for elderly
people
um give me more detail I'll just take a
just take a step back so what we're
doing today is we're announcing our plan
to recover urgent and emergency care so
this is where because we know that
people have been waiting too long in any
I've had to wait to get ambulances I
know people are really worried about
that you know if you call an ambulance
you want to know that ambulance is going
to come we want to make sure that is the
case so we've already got tons of work
going on in the NHS to improve that
during this winter but we know that also
the months ahead are going to be hard of
course you know that we've got more
people living longer that's a good thing
but with it more people who have
multiple health conditions extra
pressures on the NHS as a result so
we're putting more investment into the
NHS and specifically a billion pounds is
going into the NHS to support with this
so 5 000 more beds 800 new ambulances
the money just to pick up on that
question was announced at the awesome
statement just a couple of months ago as
part of 14 billion more from the NHS but
we're also going to do things
differently so that was to your question
about caring for people at home so this
is hospital at home sometimes called
virtual Wards which are already been
piloted in some parts of the country
they're working really well already so
you need to have that there are two ways
in which this is working at the moment
one is for instance keeping people out
of hospital if they at risk of being
admitted which is often the case of
somebody who's frail and elderly but if
you give them extra support at home then
they might not well not need to be
admitted I met somebody who was really
grateful for this and Leeds a couple of
weeks ago looked after through the
virtual by their Community Healthcare
team another model of it that's working
really well is when someone's discharged
from hospital
and knowing that you'll be remotely
monitored at home so you have to have
Wi-Fi for that to work so some of these
things do indeed rely on having a
Broadband so so having
um uh monitoring thing that checks your
blood oxygen levels yeah uh so if you
don't have a finger what happens then
well that so so what will happen when uh
doctors are considering whether somebody
can be discharged into a virtual Ward is
considering what the setup is for the
patient at home who's likely to be with
them
um and you know will they be happy for
instance to use technology actually this
is something that was started to be used
in the pandemic and because we saw lots
of people
um are you know are actually very
comfortable with using apps being online
making video calls things like that and
the patient feedback from it so far is
really good so the patient experience is
also about 5 000 more beds um how are
you going to staff those there's 133 000
vacancies so it's not just about the
beds I mean clearly a bed is actually a
kind of measure of of uh the Staffing
that goes with it so yes those beds are
staff beds that we're
we are recruiting more staff into the
NHS so for instance we set out in 2019
an ambition to have 50 000 more nurses
in the NHS by 2024 and we're on track to
have those 50 000 more nurses since 2010
we've got more than 35
000 more doctors so we're recruiting
more staff to the NHS we're also
recruiting extra support stuff okay for
instance for extra emergency medical
technicians to help paramedics and
ambulances more support staff alongside
doctors and nurses just before I let you
go our Deborah Haynes has an exclusive
report suggesting our army is no longer
a top level fighting force France have
increased their their spending by 40 on
their military Germany 100 billion uh
have up their spending budget as a
result of what's happened in Ukraine
should we be spending more money on the
NHS or on defense well you make a good
point that government has to make
difficult decisions about where we spend
money we are substantially increasing
our spending on Health and Social care
14 billion more announced at the Autumn
statement we are also substantially
investing in defense and supporting
Ukraine through these really difficult
times clearly so I don't accept that
question at all I mean we have the
largest defense spending any country in
Europe and we're in progress in a 242
billion spending plan over 10 years for
defense equipment so we really are
investing in our defense but it's still
not good enough according to the
American General that we've spoken to as
I said we're investing in our defense
because clearly keeping people safe is
the first priority of government good to
talk to you thanks very much thank you
much appreciate it
um well talking about uh Nadeem zahari
who's been stacked here's what the then
Troy leadership Contender told me when I
quizzed him about his taxes Last Summer
I need to ask you about your
investigation into your own tax Affairs
um what was your reaction when you saw
reports that your own tax Affairs were
being investigated by your own
department so I was you know clearly
being smeared I was being told that the
serious thought offers that the national
crimeacy that hmrc are looking uh into
me I've you know I'm not aware uh of
this I will I've always declared my
taxes I paid my taxes in the UK uh I was
you know answer any questions hmrc has
uh of me but I will go further okay I'm
going to make a commitment today that if
I am prime minister
I think the right thing to do is to
publish my accounts annually that's the
right thing to do because I think we
need to take this issue in many ways off
the off the table
um I will publish my accounts annually
that's the right thing to do
I will look at you know what what the
options are in terms of back dating or
just publishing annual I think it's
right to do it what about your tax
returns that's what I'm talking about my
taxes I'll publish annually okay
hmm Murray's with us um this morning uh
we don't know where Mr zahawi is anymore
he's decided to take um some time out
um
should they not have known before
well I think this is the question facing
Rishi sunak and the government in
general and to an extent Liz truss and
Boris Johnson as well as predecessors I
think the issue now is as you say those
questions about what did Rishi sunak
know and when are only going to get
louder and louder and louder until that
is fully clarified and as you saw you
know Helen Whatley there speaking to you
not very keen to be asked about this and
wouldn't really be drawn on those
details of as you say the red flags that
were raised and therefore why they were
either not passed on to the prime
minister or ignored and I think that
really smacks off either incompetence or
some level of mistakes going on behind
closed doors in number 10 whatever it is
there needs to be an explanation for why
the Prime Minister wasn't actually told
about these red flags so big big
questions to answer for Rishi tunak okay
Mary I know you're with us all morning
in Mara's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to it thanks so much indeed
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
Southern Parts can expect a mostly dry
few days while the north will be wet and
windy at times
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now for some good news to brighten up
your morning here we go guide dogs UK
has reported its first litter of the
year that's Sylvia the yellow labs
puppies at now three weeks old and will
eventually be trained to help people who
are visually impaired and you can see it
looks like mum and pops are all doing
fine look how proud she is lovely
uh Rick astein is suing rapper Young
gravy for allegedly using an
impersonation of his voice on his song
Betty get money which has racked up 500
000 sales
Never Gonna
Let You Down
[Music]
things that Rick Astley will never do
now the 80s singer said that he hadn't
agreed to his vocals being imitated and
that his distinctive voice must be
carefully managed young gravy is yet to
comment but if we know anything about
Rick Astley He's just never going to
give up on that one Izzy he's from Wigan
did you know coming up we're live to
Jerusalem where tensions are simmering
and the U.S Secretary of State is due to
arrive within hours
foreign
[Music]
Pages as they arrive there's a feeling
like some commentators that it's not the
most respectful timing I think there's a
word for it fake news I mean it's
delving deeper into the stories with
different perspectives on tomorrow's
headlines we really haven't seen the
government getting around the table and
negotiating there are no easy answers to
those questions the Press preview
delivering you tomorrow's news tonight
on Sky News
hello again everybody you are watching
Sky News just want to update you on some
breaking news reaching us here at Sky
Center a major search underway to find a
45 year old woman from Inskip in
Lancashire who vanished while walking
her dog
um Nicola bully last seen two days ago
at around uh in fact three days ago now
at around 9 15 a.m on a foot path by the
river wire Off garstang Road in the
village of Saint Michael's on wire
emergency crews including Lancashire
police Lancashire fire and rescue Boland
Pennine Mountain Rescue and Northwest
underwater search teams have all joined
the search police dive teams fire
service drones search dogs helicopters
and Mountain rescue volunteers have been
sent to the area Lancashire police said
Ms Bully's dog a brown spaniel has been
found close to where she was last seen
and hope this might help jog the memory
of anyone who saw her at around the same
time and who may have information
relating to her whereabout but she's
five foot three light brown shoulder
length hair and speaks with an Essex
accent
in other news the U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken is flying into Jerusalem
later on today arriving after a spike in
israeli-palestinian violence and
increasingly sharp rhetoric from both
sides and a Sprinkle standing by for us
in Jerusalem this morning hi Alistair
what's going on
Wednesday blinken's been in Cairo
overnight Egypt really is the main
mediators often between the Palestinians
and the Israelis when things get tense
so he started his three-day trip to the
Middle East there he arrives in Tel Aviv
later on this afternoon around lunchtime
your time he'll come up here to
Jerusalem for talks with the current the
new Israeli government including the
Prime Minister bibin Netanyahu and then
tomorrow he will go to Ramallah in the
West Bank for talks with the Palestinian
Authority and he comes at a moment when
this region is on edge there's been
significant violence over the last week
it is threatening to spiral out of
control and he will come with a message
from the White House that the Israeli
government and the Palestinians need to
take steps to calm it down it's not his
first visit here he's been a number of
times before the CI director William
Burns was here recently as well the U.S
as ever is very engaged in U.S
Palestinian issues but with a new you
right-wing Israeli government I think
the question is is are they in a
position or in a mood to listen to them
okay for now thank you
strike ballot overpay will be announced
later on today if members of the fire
brigades union vote for Action it will
be the first time it's happened
Nationwide in 20 years the fbu has said
that in the last 12 years firefighters
have seen a 12 real terms pay cut with
one in five jobs lost joining us now
General Secretary of the fire brigade
Union that's Matt rack
um hello to Mr X good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning uh what can we expect
um if there is
um a strike
good morning okay well we we still hope
that we can avoid a strike uh we don't
intend to put strike dates in as
straight away after the results we've
asked for a meeting with our employers
we've given them additional 10 days and
have agreed to meet us on the 8th of
February so we hope that they wake up to
how serious the situation is they hope
we hope they wake up to how angry
firefighters are at fall in pay and they
make an improved offer otherwise there
would then be strike dates put in but as
I say there's a chance for them and the
government to step in and avert this
level of conflict
why do you want to strike
well we don't want to strive nobody
wants to strive workers lose money when
they strike but uh firefighters are
prepared to strike uh because they are
fed up and angry at the level of uh
attack on their pay 12 years of seeing
their pay fall in real terms while their
jobs are also cut and the service is
also suffers an endless decline we get
to fire slower and slower each year and
they're not prepared to accept that they
love their job they want to serve their
communities but they've also got
families and bills to pay and you can't
pay that when your wages keep getting
cut
um Mr rack I'm reading in my newspaper
that cleaners and HR staff could
reportedly called on to answer 999 calls
if there is industrial action surely
that's not the case
I'm not I'm not familiar with that the
question of what is put in place when we
go on strike is a matter that would have
to be addressed to the fire service
employers or to the government that's
their responsibility as I say our our
attempt is to seek to avoid a strike uh
the employers and the government need to
wake up to the failure to invest in the
fire and rescue Service as in other
public services but in our case in the
fire and rescue service and they need to
do something serious to avoid a dispute
and they can only do that by sitting
around the table with us and improving
their pay offer and I hope they do that
very quickly so suggestions that fire
services around the country are training
up back office staff to bolster
Frontline Services you're not aware of
that
well they may be doing that they don't
involve Us in those discussions those
are discussions that they will have with
themselves and I think the questions
better directed to them I I'm not
involved in any of that discussion what
I'm involved in is talking to our
members and then seeking to talk to the
government and to the employers so that
they can improve their payoffer and we
can avoid getting into a strike in the
first place
how much alarm would it cause you and
your members that a cleaner was on a
shout well clearly in our view
training for a firefighting job is a
very serious matter it takes years in
fact to become a competent firefighter
and in our view nothing should be done
to undermine that level of competence so
if that is what is being done that's
totally inadequate
um thank you for taking the time to join
us I know the vote result will be at
around about five o'clock um this
evening and we'll probably hopefully
chat to you again after that but for now
thank you thank you very much
well the brutality laid bear in the
police body cam footage of the beating
of 29 year old Tire Nichols has shocked
people in the United States and indeed
across the globe Tire died three days
after the violent assault by five police
officers who have all been charged with
second-degree murder given the vicious
nature of the footage some people are
deciding not to watch it um Dr Shola
um is with us um hi good to see you
thanks for joining us I know that you
don't want to see the video
um we've heard from his mum Rowan well
she says that she hopes that his death
will lead to change I would like that
too but there they've just been too many
from between George Floyd and today
nothing has changed I very much doubt
that anything would change until we
eradicate the source of this problem
which is white supremacy listen The
Vicious and brutal on just the black
this is why I'm about to educate some
people right now the vicious brutal
unjustified extrajudicial killing or
Tyree Nichols is as a result of a police
system that is built on white supremacy
white supremacy underpins the policing
and Criminal Justice System both in the
United States and the United Kingdom it
shapes the culture that sees black
people as less treats black lives as
disposable and ensures that black lives
don't matter look what I'm trying to
explain here is that there is a systemic
reality of white supremacy that produces
racist white cops and racial gatekeeping
black and brown cops okay this is the
reality and this is what black people
have to deal with this is and this does
not absolve in any way shape from a
manner the individual responsibility of
the police officers and I'm sure that
they're good police officers listening
right now that would say no listen the
point of the police is to protect and
serve and we try to do this look I agree
the point of the police is protect
itself but the reality is that good
police they are the exception not the
norm and the reality is what we see
every day now there'll be people also
watching right now going first of all
because they're black police officers it
means it's not racist no it means that
you've not educated yourself on how
systemically white supremacy Works black
and brown racial Gatekeepers exist in
policing exist in our Health Care system
in our politics they exist everything
everywhere and their point and their
representation is to represent white
supremacy not people of their own race
now there'll be people argue right now
oh that's a left way of thinking no
that's a Humanity way of thinking this
is why activists like myself have always
been very careful when we say
representation matters diversity matters
but you do not go and put bring somebody
whose whole representation is to
represent exactly what is against us and
say that's your representation Dr Shola
that person's black I'm like no that
person is not my representation because
what they stand for is everything I
stand against so how do you how does
society start particularly the United
Society in the United States start to
address that okay so we need to
understand that you cannot treat
rehabilitate white supremacy you need to
eradicate it and quite frankly wipe the
ideology of white supremacy off the face
of the Earth and you mentioned the
United States okay it exists here in the
United Kingdom please let me name some
names Joy Gardner who was killed in 1993
with God and Sean reads in 2018
Roshan and Charles in 2017 think about
Jimmy mubenga Sarah Reed Sarah Reed was
in 2012. umeo was in 2015. I mean the
list goes on these are people who died
in custody and by the hands of British
police officers we need to take it's
it's going to take more than moral
courage it's going to take more than
just having pull least do the right
thing we as a society have to be able to
stand up and say no more we recognize
what white supremacy is doing in our
policing system in our criminal justice
system do you notice how quickly these
five black police thugs let's not call
them officers right how quickly they
were arrested and charged and fired that
is unprecedented because every other
white cop that's actually even though
works by killing black people or
leeching them on the spot they didn't
get fired immediately did they get
arrested immediately or child but still
at the end of the day white supremacy
always finds its way and this black
officers will most likely they will most
likely get longer sentences they will
most likely there will be Justice sin to
be done because that they're black so it
is the UK and the US that must address
the issue of white supremacy we should
have a national and International
Register that clearly lists the names of
um police officers black white and brown
who are who have been known to commit
domestic abuse racial abuse all of these
things they are not fit for office they
should not be there that's the people
that's the individual but we must also
look at what underpins policing that
treats black people this way and it's
white supremacy people wake up it's 2023
we've had Keenan Anderson now we have
Tyree um Nichols think about it this is
the source of the problem and the fact
that even after the global black lives
matter protest in 2020 and everybody
said oh we're so shocked at what
happened to George Floyd absolutely
another zilch nothing has changed why is
that let me ask you one final question
before I let you go are we talking
um well I wanted to talk to you about
legal building blocks at the George
George Floyd Justice and policing act
introduced in 2021 but it's been held up
in the Senate talk to us briefly about
that I think the reality is that when
politics steps into it Humanity flies
out
um this is similar similar to God reform
law laws not taking place in the United
States or the fact that the Voting
Rights Act to struggle to even see any
light of day again I come back to the
issue of white supremacy it is not in
the interests of these politicians that
are holding back change through law to
ensure that that George Floyd acts is
the light of day and let's remember that
the law also is not the whole solution
okay the law people hide behind the law
and people use the law to enforce evil
reforms or else think about it why is
that nothing has changed so it is
important to have the law it is
important to enact that but it's also
important to change the mindset it is
important to always Shine the Light on
what the evil is Call It by its name
it's white supremacy it's racist and
that they are black and brown racial
Gatekeepers who enforce that white
supremacy ideology never have enough
time to talk to you we must leave it
there Dr Charlotte it's always great to
see you thank you very much thank you
that's move on to the story about
defense sources should we revealing to
Sky news that a senior U.S general has
privately told the defense secretary Ben
Wallace that the British army is no
longer regarded as a top level Fighting
Force One anonymous source says the
British army is unable to protect the UK
and our allies for a decade following
years of cuts to defense spending let's
get more on this now with the former
deputy chief of the defense staff so
Simon male hello to Simon thank you very
much on the program what do you make of
Deborah's excellent report well it's
it's um at this point you'd read but it
is something we have warned about for a
long time
our Baseline assumption was always we'd
be in any major war the major Ally of
the United States there was a basic
assumption they were the uh the leading
Western power and we wish to be we wish
the Americans have an assumption that if
they went to war and it was something
backed by governments you in the United
Nations Etc that the natural Ally that
would come with a large contribution
would be the United Kingdom and we've
taken our eye very firmly off the ball I
have to say it's most Western countries
have over the last decades um using
defenses as a peace dividend well we
assumed there'd be no major war and
we've been rudely awakened at a time
when the chickens are probably coming
home to roost in terms of our investment
what do you say to those who say you
know we are the biggest spending um in
Europe on defense yes I would but
Everything's Relative
um people say well we can't afford
defense because the reality is we choose
not to afford defense uh we all took
advantage of the peace dividend after
the fall of the Berlin Wall uh to up uh
obviously Health spending welfare uh
spending all of them very very worthy
worthy costs but the primary the primary
responsibility of any government is the
defense of the nation defense of its
citizens and its interests and those are
not simply at the uh at the um uh the
The Cliffs of Dover
um and ultimately of course um uh you
know numbers aren't everything we
utterly understand that you're going to
look at Ukraine uh it's the spirit it's
the fighting spiritual and Armed Forces
but to an extent quantity does have a
quality of its own and we have
undermined and so there is a size at
which the Americans would quite rightly
say you cannot produce anything of any
real substance you know of critical
substances in the sort of time frames we
we would want and we've always held that
as a benchmark of our assumption about
our our place in the in the world and in
the nation as a really genuinely
credible uh military force
we were moving away from Battlefield War
though I went way in and instead moving
towards cyber war was that it was quite
obviously a mistake I know there was a
mistake uh you know the battlefield
changes without doubt uh and it's not
always one or the other and I can see
the attraction of moving to things like
cyber because Wars as we see so horribly
in Ukraine do involve casualties you
know people are killed people are
wounded there's a huge attrition rate
and what we've proved in sadly proved in
in Ukraine is not only do you need an
organization with breath but you need
depth as well and uh you know the
casualties are horrendous there
um and it is a war of attrition and
Logistics as well material so it's not
simply numbers of Tanks or even soldiers
it's just how much underpins it in terms
of uh
um
spare parts in terms of replacement
vehicles in terms of certainly
ammunition
um and that is of course what you're
seeing about the debate about 14
challenge attacks the tanks are fine but
where the crews where's the training
we're the spare parts and where the
ammunition stocks that make a bit of
equipment into a capability and that
that I think lies behind the American
criticism is that we still have
obviously a very good army we're very
very proud of our soldiers our officers
um you know my own regiments just back
from Marley done a fantastic job
um and our own soldiers will will be
disappointed but if you want to keep
good people in yeah you need to have an
organization that looks like like it's
growing and thriving must be music to
the years of President Putin it will be
um and of course let's be honest this is
partly behind his calculation when he
went into Ukraine uh that the European
nations and let's again not just beat up
ourselves about this we remain a highly
credible capable Armed Forces our our
Navy our Royal Air Force our Marines and
and certainly our army my own service
are still highly capable we still invest
a lot but we've got to be realistic
about the threats that we face and I
think uh Putin when he looked at going
into Ukraine he looked at political will
look the reality of what the Great
armies might be able to do you better go
look at Germany and France they're the
other sort of a peer group peer group
Western European conventional armies
must have thought I'll I'll factor that
into my gamble they're not they're not
ready to contribute anything other than
good words for a number of years to come
so it's a build back we must leave it
there thank you very much India for
joining us thank you program thank you I
actually went I'm not sure if you caught
my interview
um with President zielinski we went to
Ukraine uh last week to Kiev to be
precise talk to him about all sorts of
things including president uh Putin
um it was actually his 45th birthday
while we were there and today we're
wishing a very happy birthday to a man
who's more than worthy of a killer drum
roll intro
[Music]
oh yeah Phil Collins celebrating his
72nd birthday today former Genesis
frontman has of course been both the
voice and drummer behind a number of
iconic songs over the years but his
first solo hits in the air tonight is
arguably his most famous
happy birthday Bill Collins coming up in
just a few moments time Nadeem zahawi
has he been treated badly stay tuned for
more here on Sky
[Music]